and so I look at this problem as a
complex systems problem like a health
problem we have one patient patient is
planet Earth
our state of medicine it's about 18th
19th century and we're in pretty
critical condition and so we have a
complex systems problem and coming from
IT infrastructure again you know what we
need is data on the various layers of
the system we need good much better
tools than we have for analyzing that
data and looking at the system in a
variety of different types of ways the
good news is we have technologies that
we have not applied to this problem yet
that exists for other things so the
disruptions and remote sensing drones
surface aerial space most of that stuff
has not been applied to this problem at
all
and likewise with computing and models
and analytics so I worked on a project
with ocean climate risk that was taking
approaches to studying complex systems
in finance and IT and applying them to
study ocean climate risk so one of the
ways I look at this is that the full
weight and force of what the tech
industry knows how to do has not been
applied to the problem of understanding
the climate system that's good news
because that's low-hanging fruit so we
could understand understand the system a
lot better and a lot faster and if we
want to intervene in the system I would
argue that we have to and I've talked to
politicians and and people on the left
and the right and what I tell them is
that if you're interested in intervening
in the climate system we have to
understand it much better than we do
today
and we have to make investments in the
scientists the platforms and the
capabilities that we need to understand
the Earth's system better it's a
prerequisite for any intervention that
we do so that's part of the whole deal
here and in order to do that we have the
mother of all interdisciplinary problems
and so I don't know if you can read this
chart but the disciplines involved go
from nano scale particles
narration through you know localized
weather systems all the way up to global
climate data and information systems
civil and environmental risk and control
systems all the way into human and
societal operations and the way we make
decisions together as a human population
so that's a tricky one and I'm gonna
argue that we need to do all of the
studying that we need to do in the next
decade because of the timelines that I
pointed out earlier in the conversation
so for me the question is how can how
can we coordinate an agenda to learn
what we need to know about possible
options for protecting ourselves from
heat risk in the context of the kind of
damages that we might be looking at even
if there are only possibilities by the
middle of the century and so to that end
there are some different kinds of
exploration that we need to do
technologies we need to develop the
aerosol generation all share with with
you guys and we'll talk a little bit
more about the fact that there really
aren't research programs today there are
no formal sources of funding in this
area and to my knowledge the only place
in the world where the developing
aerosol technologies to to try to
perform these techniques and understand
them is here in Silicon Valley and it's
a team that's comprised the half a dozen
retired engineers
so I'm whom co-invented inkjet printing
in the optical mouse and they've been
working on this problem for six years
for their grandchildren without pay now
that work is likely to move into a more
formalized setting where we can work
more actively on different approaches
and different ways to scale it up but
the technology is critical to
understanding what might be possible and
where we're going to feed into our
models and analytics and so alongside
the technology for dispersion we need
lots of improvements to our climate
models and analytics and we need
specific models and analytics that look
at these specific types of approaches
and I could talk to you a lot about some
of the limitations of
in our reliance on them to make
decisions about climate for any of you
have worked on complex systems you know
that a big part of the challenge is
looking at the systems in different ways
and there are different ways you poke at
the system and analyze the system and in
climate we've been using primarily
simulations and simulations are
particularly bad at picking up the kind
of complex system dynamics like abrupt
change and so it's particularly likely
that we may be under estimating the kind
of changes that we're facing so we need
to improve these badly and we need to
get more systems people using more
different ways of looking at the system
and then experiments so once you have
just a technology and you've done some
modeling work process level studies of
what happens when you release particles
into the atmosphere
how they interact with the cloud how
they flow out into the stratosphere
those are really crucial at very small
scales they can give you a lot of
information to feed into models and
estimate what's going to happen so there
are a couple of proposed experiments or
experimental programs this one is a
picture of the program at Harvard which
is the most well funded program in the
world for looking at brightening the
atmosphere it's headed by a
well-regarded well known scientist named
David Keith it's an interdisciplinary
program that's been trying to look at
the societal aspects of doing this as
well but they're proposing experiment in
the stratosphere using a balloon where
they would release a number of different
kinds of materials only a leader each so
they'll be very lucky if they can
measure what comes out but they're
looking to determine some of the initial
chemistry the interactions with those
different kinds of materials in the
stratosphere and maybe something about
the way they disperse and that would be
the first step in a very long sequence
of studies both in modeling and in
experiments and in data to try to get a
grasp on whether this would work what
material you would want to use and what
kind of bounds you could put on there
of it so that program is is happening
they don't I don't believe they have a
definitive date for that experiment but
I think they hope to do it sometime in
the next year and the University of
Washington is the home of the program
which is not funded and so consists of
researchers working in their voluntary
spare time together with the engineers
who've been working in their retirement
but what they hope to do is a sequence
of steps that will go from generating a
single plume overland plume over the
ocean and then finally a patch of ocean
and clouds that they would brighten with
multiple ships and try to measure
changes in the reflectivity and that
whole sequence that they would like to
do to measure changes in reflectivity of
a patch of ocean and sky which would be
your first experiment and whether you
can brighten the cloud they think will
take 8 to 10 years to do that sequence I
press them on it like well if we have
money we go faster okay
so but but to give you a sense both of
these experiments that I described are
below the level where the EPA would even
engage them for a review so they don't
contain physical risks with regard to
the kinds of parameters that we have
today for putting things into the
atmosphere the people are worried about
them for other reasons like the
precedents that they might set or the
societal forces they might set into
motion
[Music]